vous arrêtez de délirer là vous avez
picoler ou quoi euh non moi j'y vais pas
c'est comme ça que tu m'aimes donc
[Rires]
j'ai le louche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes ici ce soir pour un livre
intitulé non je ne suis pas le fils de
Claude Lelouch exactement
vous êtes la seule star elle s'appelait
Gilles mais je sais je sais les gilles
Moreton j'en veux tellement mes parents
de m'avoir appelé c'est quoi cette idée
je suis pas agile c'est un prénom de
berger mais c'est pas c'est pas un
prénom d'acteurs de Philippe Lellouche
qui lui-même et le mari de Vanessa
Demouy vous êtes également l'ami de Jean
Dujardin tout comme Nicolas Bedos je
vais voir une liste d'attentat croyable
pour devenir amis de gens du jardin il y
a des bus alors Hollywood dans les
années 60 il y avait ce qu'on appelait
le ratpack alors c'était Frank Sinatra
Dean Martin c'est midi junior Peter law
Ford et en France on a le ratpack
maintenant notre ratpack à nous c'est
Jean Dujardin Gilles Lellouche et
Nicolas Bedos alors pour entrer dans la
bande c'est très compliqué il faut boire
trois votes catholiques par le nez
raconter des blagues de cul et choper
une meuf en moins de 10 minutes dans une
boîte et avoir lu un livre avoir lu un
livre j'ai oublié donc ne pas être
Alessandra Sublet
[Rires]
c'est vrai que vous êtes très copain
quoi
ça fait très longtemps qu'on se connaît
tous ici donc c'est pas du tout une
amitié opportuniste ou professionnelle
c'est qu'on est on est pas vraiment et
vous êtes très proche de gens donc vous
d'ailleurs dans la scène de sodomie des
infidèles c'est vous qui faites la
cascade tout faire en vrai alors vous
savez que ça on l'a tiré au sort quand
même on l'a fait à pile ou face et j'ai
gagné en fait j'ai gagné j'ai gagné du
tout
disons que j'avais la meilleure position
c'est toi qui a eu cette idée en plus
non moi je trouve que tu as perdu
[Rires]
j'ai parlé de la possibilité qu'à la fin
du film il y a cette conclusion
[Rires]
alors Gilles vous êtes ici ce soir pour
un film sans Jean Dujardin ça m'arrive
de temps en temps
ça s'appelle Gibraltar c'est un film de
Julien Leclerc qui avait réalisé
l'assaut avec ta Rahim Ricardo Scamarcio
celui de romans sont criminel et de
normes bien entendu alors c'est
l'histoire de Marc Duval donc un
Français expatrié à Gibraltar qui pour
mettre sa famille à l'abri du besoin
devient aviseur des douanes françaises
et se retrouve embarqué dans l'univers
des narcotrafiquants
c'est c'est dur c'est non seulement dur
mais c'est surtout une histoire vraie
histoire de marquer
ici c'est vraiment arrivé et qui a dédié
six ans et demi de sa vie à cette
entoure le plat et 10 ans de prison
surtout il avait un espèce de
bar-restaurant dans lequel tous les
narcotrafiquants se retrouvaient pour
jouer William et discutait de leur
trafic et donc on leur en lui a demandé
de venir indique d'indique il est devenu
convoyeur de convoyeur il est devenu
lui-même dealer enfin il s'est retrouvé
dans une position inouïe en étant censé
être protégé par l'État ce qu'il était
de temps en temps
il a été trahi c'est un indique légal
qui a été trahi par les temps exactement
même sans Dujardin c'est bien j'arrive à
m'en sortir même sans lui
en ce moment vous tournez avec lui je
vais par la semaine prochaine
c'est l'histoire du juge Michel exécuté
de deux balles dans la tête et une dans
le thorax par le milieu marseillais
alors à l'époque ça allait beaucoup
choqué maintenant à Marseille c'est une
mort naturelle
quasi et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu